foreign
this is talk TV
tonight on Facebook and our sensitive
failure becomes fast the British
government implodes over unfunded tax
cuts the crisis they caused raises on
what now for this trust is economic
strategy I'll talk to the boss of a
think tank dubbed the brains behind the
policy
plus Fury the filthy desecration of a
memorial to national hero Captain to Tom
Moore I'll take on one of the protesters
who supports this live in the studio
live
Piers Morgan uncensored good evening
London welcome to Piers Morgan
uncensored let's be clear this wasn't a
U-turn a U-turn means turning around and
going back in the direction you came
from you can't turn a car around you've
driven it off a cliff that's exactly
what Liz truss and quasi quattang have
done with the British economy taking the
reputation of a conservative party
possibly their own political careers
with them so turning back now they're
Reckless arrogant decisions have already
cost the bridge economy billions they've
already blown up mortgages Millions now
face crippling new bills in the middle
of the worst cost living crisis in
memory because of their actions the
markets panic when they announce their
unfunded tax cuts simply because
investors have no confidence in the
government tell me exactly why they or
anybody else should have confidence in
this here's quasi-quarting a couple of
days after announcing his disastrous
policy
so we're bringing forward uh the cut in
the basic rate and there's more to come
we've only been here 19 days I want to
see uh over the next year people retain
more of their income
pouring more and more fuel onto the fire
he'd started for the record here's what
I said the very next day
with their massive tax cuts mostly for
the rich prime minister list trust and
Chancellor quasi quateng have taken a
reckless gamble with our economy and so
far that gamble is failing so how did
that gamble work out well the pound
crashed interest rates Spike the bank of
England had to intervene to save
pensions and millions of people still
yesterday fingers in her ears prime
minister Liz truss said this to the
BBC's Laura coonsberg
are you absolutely committed to
abolishing a 45 Pence tax rate for the
wealthiest people in the country yes
well she was but it turned out only for
a few hours because the very next
morning this morning she reversed the
chancellor well he came out and said
this
we were focused on delivering the growth
plan there's a lot of good stuff in the
growth plan and what was clear talking
to lots of people up and down the
country talking to MPS talking to voters
talking to our constituents was that the
45p rate was becoming a huge distraction
a distraction a distraction Chancellor
would be if they fly suddenly moved past
my head
and distracted me what you did collapse
the economy destroyed the pound
temporarily and even with the markets in
meltdown you and your prime minister
spent a full week doubling down on your
ridiculous decision
and you knew best we were all wrong
I asked tonight How can any of us trust
them again
with our finances they wanted to cut
taxes for the rich they refused to tax
energy companies as they rolled in their
billions of unexpected profits they
lifted any cap on Bankers bonuses all
with no independent Financial oversight
didn't even tell their cabinet about
half this stuff this was always going to
be a tone-death disaster the only people
who couldn't see that were running the
country well now confidence in them is
shattered perhaps permanently because
First Impressions last that's why this
isn't the U-turn it's a car crash and
they're expecting us to pay for the
repairs well joining me now is talk to
people who live in Cape McCann okay I
have seen some whopping mistakes in my
time this is one of the biggest I can
remember to have to basically do a
u-turn on this huge tax cut policy on
the morning of your own conference when
you've only been in the job three weeks
I mean for quasi quateng a disaster the
list trusted disaster for the
conservative party a disaster
yeah I mean look it's actually in some
ways even worse than that because how it
came about last night was absolutely
fascinating I mean we're all here at
Conservative Party Conference you know
peers that these events don't end at
normal working day time seven eight
o'clock they go on until midnight one
o'clock two o'clock in the morning and
so there was a party last night where
Liz truss gave a speech it was for the
1922 committing conservative home really
an audience of her biggest supporters
she's still on the stage she said I'm
all for difficult decisions
conservatives tax cuts I love the city I
love business we shouldn't be ashamed of
making these arguments essentially I'm
not going to U-turn but crucially she
had already when she gave that speech
made the decision to do exactly that to
go back on that 45p tax rate and so
those in the room looking back on it are
now wondering well hang on a minute what
was she saying to us when she was
promising all these difficult decisions
would be stuck to and again you know a
late night party last night journalists
and cabinet ministers there this whisper
goes around the room that the 45p rape
policy is gone and the immediate
response was no surely not they're not
going to do that are they even cabinet
ministers didn't believe it didn't know
about it weren't told about it some of
them including Jacob rees-mogg found out
this morning from a text message by
Therese coffee the Deputy Prime Minister
this is a party that has been rocked by
the response to what they saw many of
them as a fundamentally conservative
budget they didn't expect what happened
to happen in the markets and now they
are trying to reassure both the markets
and the party here that they are still
the right people for the job the problem
is is that the conservative party has
always traded off its economic
credibility and when you knock into that
particularly the time when labor is
trying to gather momentum in the polls
but things can look pretty dangerous for
you well they can I thought one of the
worst things that they did in the whole
farcical process was the Prime Minister
yesterday so admitting they'd failed to
do the groundwork for this mini budget I
mean how could you fail to do the
groundwork for a budget of this
magnitude with the repercussions and
implications so so gigantic it just
seemed to me a complete failure of
economic competence from a party which
has always prided itself on being the
party of economic competence
yeah and I think a lot of people heard
that from the Prime Minister and had
some questions about it because she had
laid a significant amount of economic
ground work in her leadership way she'd
indicated that she was going to make the
tax cuts that she wanted to and then did
do in the mini budget the problem was
that they then went further the 45p tax
rate was a surprise to most of the
cabinet when they heard it in the House
of Commons and the indication as you
said from quasi quaten the chancellor
the next day that there would be more to
come those are the things that the
markets really reacted to they priced in
a lot of the other elements of this
there were some questions about
borrowing yes but some of those closest
to list trust are economic advisors
those within the circle had warned her
go steady don't do anything too rash the
Market's a jittery just do what you have
to do send a signal yes but don't go too
far and for some reason they chose not
to listen and now they're trying to wind
that bag and it is difficult the mood
here you know usually the conservative
party has quite a buoyant conference
there are a lot of MPS here you do not
have to go very far with even asked them
a question for them to start telling you
how bad things are even I have to say
the ones who are out defending the
government behind the scenes they say
well we'll lose our seats this is
probably going to be my last Party
Conference maybe the last but one we're
not in a great place there's actually
almost looks like a sort of Funeral
Parlor behind you uh tonight which is
probably the right kind of mood uh final
question and a quick one okay as you you
look at as you look around the morgue
um I would say very very very high
likelihood that that one of either
quasi-quarting or less trust or
potentially both gone by Christmas will
you take that bet
no
and I know we've been here before and I
know how it ended last time but no
because there is no appetite in the
party for a new leadership contest and
because Liz truss has firmly tied her
wagon to quasi-quarters and I don't
think she can get rid of him I might be
wrong I think that's well you were wrong
last time and I think you'll be wrong
again you should trust you should just
trust Old Mystic Morgan I'm afraid uh
Kate McCain good to talk to you we'll be
back with you tomorrow night good luck
down there don't ever enjoy the
atmosphere my god
um good to see well let's get into my uh
get into my panel tonight former
conservative Minister Alan whittakam
former newspaper editor Emily shevlin
columnist and the chief data reporter
for the financial times John Burr metal
so John let me start with you because we
need someone with your pedigree Chief
data reporter of EFT number crunch this
in language we can understand
in all your time
covering economic matters have you ever
seen such a cack-handed display of
economic incompetence by government it's
pretty astonishing isn't it I think that
the key thing here is that it wasn't
just that this was a big move it was a
completely unforced move you know a lot
of people asked last week um why the
markets responded to this that most of
the the sort of fiscal
um weight of what was announced in a
mini budget was stuff that had been been
leaked before the the bulk of it was the
energy bill
um the the energy price guarantee but
the the key point is that was sensible
that was something that any government
any Economist any member of the public
looks at and says okay I can see why
that was done we needed that it cost a
lot of money but it was necessary you
look at something like cutting the top
tax rate or or getting rid of the
capital Bankers bonuses and sure well
the well the numeric amounts in terms of
the additional uh borrowing was or the
additional sort of fiscal costs were
smaller it's what it signaled and I
think it just signaled that this is a
government a leadership that has
completely abandoned economic Orthodoxy
and completely unmoored itself from
where the British population is on these
issues at a time when economic issues
the cost of living or the fourth at the
Forefront of everyone's Minds I mean
you're shaking your head and I'll come
to you why you're doing that in a moment
but it just seemed to me that the Optics
of the whole mini budget were completely
skewed it just looked like they were
trying to reduce taxation on wealthy
people but they were trying to spare
bankers and take away all their bonus
caps that they weren't going to punish
energy companies with a windfall tax
because they wanted them to flourish too
meanwhile you've got all these millions
of people really suffering and this cost
living crisis going well whose side are
you on here
well that is uh the pr failure and and
it was a very very big failure and I
think if Liz trust failed to lay the
ground at all it was in the preparation
for the reasoning for it now if you just
take the cap on Bankers bonuses for
example
um the idea is that because all the EU
does have a cap if we didn't have a cap
we would be more competitive we would
attract investment now that isn't
something that happens 24 hours later
but it's something that does happen and
that was the reasoning behind it it
wasn't to give the rich a break it was
to actually no but I'm talking about the
politics of it yeah yes okay let me come
to you you might be talking about a
reality I've seen people defend it but
when you put those three things together
yeah the combined effect was we're
looking after the wealthiest people in
society well first of all that 150
billion that we've spent on the energy
price cap to try and keep down bills for
households 150 billion a mere 2 billion
if that it was probably going to be cost
neutral
[Laughter]
the problem is if you suddenly see
mortgages and uh Rising pensions
crashing and so on then the the damage
that is done by this mini budget far out
does any of the benefits you're talking
about it's like this all happened hence
the screeching YouTube first of all you
were hysterical last week but and the
pound has now gone back uh and uh as far
as pensions go there was also an a bit
of risky trading that was going on
anyway so it wasn't just a budget but
those things people don't take in what
really flabbergastes me is that after
all that talk that tough talk you know
the talk about being Churchill if you
like they've actually turned into the
Grand Old Duke of York well that's it I
mean that's interesting thing right so
Emily I mean the problem for Liz truss
is she was going to be the new Thatcher
she wouldn't be for turning she would
take the difficult decisions and stick
by them and in the space of literally 10
days she's performed a massive U-turn
humiliating U-turn she's proved she is
for turning and she ain't no Margaret
Thatcher and it's about a fiddling
little thing like the two billion well
it may be fiddling to you
I don't think it is she she looks
utterly incompetent so does her
Chancellor because this was three weeks
in
Stitch like someone's running into a
party to announce themselves and in
their brand new frog and everyone thinks
okay we'll just have a look at this girl
I'm literally falling flat on her face
yeah I think she is completely lost
credibility
I think they can survive but you've got
to think the U-turn everyone's focusing
on the tax cut U-turn today they didn't
just u-turn on the tax cut they had to
praise to high heaven our British
institutions the bank of England they're
having I think they're going to have to
bring forward that obr report they can't
leave that till the 23rd of November and
they spent the summer slagging off the
Civil Service and treasury Orthodoxy
they look so
stupid sorry Reckless the obr report is
actually being brought forward
either way credibility
whether you take Emily in my view which
is this has been a total disaster and
therefore damaging all your view which
is a shown political weakness which is
also very damaging either way they're
very damaged that is undeniably true I
mean they are the polls are catastrophic
I mean today another poll just coming
out Redfield and Wilton strategies are
28-point lead a Kia started
do you think they're getting better dude
but you said whether do you think she
can survive the problem is and you're
about to have the Ia yeah director on I
think because even he said this morning
having said on radio Forge oh I've never
seen her change her mind well I mean we
have through her career she's often
changed her mind about a lot of things
but and I don't mind flexibility in
politicians actually a bigger problem
now is her position in the party is so
weakened this this isn't going to be the
only things you turns on we're going to
see how you turn on so many difficulties
well they've got her on the run I mean
you can right this is the thing got an
incredibly weak right when you've got
people like you know Michael Gove and
Grant straps all the ones who basically
left the stage but are festering away
about what's gone down when you see them
all taking her on and getting an
immediate win that to me is a real
problem for an incumbent new prime
minister because the confidence from her
own party seems to be less than it is in
the wider Community absolutely okay I
just think it was astonishingly bad
politics I think that the key thing in
the polls is the Tory is obviously a key
thing for them in 2019 was winning over
this chunk of former labor voters those
labor voters are left-wing if you come
out and say we're going to cut taxes for
the rich you've immediately lost them
and you can see that in the polls now
about one in five people who voted
toward the last election and now saying
they're going to vote labor right it's
the voters it's the the more moderate
members of the party I think that the
red wall would have hated this minibus
absolutely it gets almost a mini budget
it's bigger than most budgets I've ever
seen even he said today he called it a
budget yeah I think the other
interesting thing is his body language I
mean there was a moment here in his in
his speech today uh to the Tories where
he he sort of almost looks like he's
enjoying himself watch this
but I can be frank I know the plan put
forward only 10 years days ago has
caused a little turbulence I get it I
get it uh we are listening and have
listened and now I want to focus on
delivering a little turbulence chuckle
chuckle from the party faithful are they
still not getting this do they not
realize the damage they've done to the
British public mortgage rates I mean
they're getting a little turbulence and
you've got people who are trying to buy
a house now are trying to refix their
mortgage and they're screwed like you
mentioned this earlier the the amount of
money we were talking about households
losing as a result of the entire cost of
living crisis pales in comparison to
what people are refixing their mortgage
will hit now right that's this is people
interest rates were going up those
mortgage packages will return so you
know about 300 removed you could still
get a mortgage for about I don't think
it was about three to four percent so
there's interest rates are going up the
catastrophic thing for the trust
government now is they every they are
going to own that and and interest rates
were going up and the bank of England
would have carried on I mean I watched
quasi quality the chancellor is the
piles so much the Chancellor's job is to
make is to be calm stable and make us
all feel reassured I watched a guy today
is to fire up the economy and that was
what they were trying to do for growth
I'm all for that that's what they were
trying yes to do but they've achieved
the complete opposite well I don't think
they've necessarily achieved the
complete opposite because what they have
what's grown up oh don't be silly
as if something grows within a few days
of a budget you grow up but what
actually what
I'm trying to individual personal debts
in households because they can't afford
because we've already heard there was a
trend that was happening anywhere and
you didn't hear that from a friend of
the government just now so but let me
say I mean I despise the U-turn but what
they were trying to do and by
sacrificing the 45p actually they have
sacrificed what could have described as
a distraction
um but by what they were trying to do
was to stimulate growth and it is
crucial that they do that and they've
been saying for months and months that
you know they were going to be a tax
cutting government yes it's all real
world leadership it's like and then they
try to do that
if I'm saying it's going to be sunny for
months and then it pulls a
rainy they were borrowing money for tax
cuts that doesn't work and we still
don't know how they were going to find
the drive growth that doesn't actually
they've driven they've driven us over a
cliff haven't driven any growth let's
take a short break when a company can
talk to the man who despite today's
return has full confidence in Liz
trusses government but then he would his
think tanked by a lot of our ideas we'll
talk to Mark littlewood the Ia director
plus a disgusting dirty protest at the
memorial to Captain
more I'll talk to somebody who supports
it
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to Piers of organized
Center there's Tory poll ratings
plummeted with the pound last week the
embattled Prime Minister one Relentless
cheerleader Institute of economic
Affairs is a free market Think Tank
which is a long relationship with Liz
truss she even created the Free
Enterprise Group which which is
effectively a parliamentary body
representing the iea's ideas in
Westminster or director general of the
iea Martin
thank you very much indeed for joining
me I want to replay you at the start of
this interview something you said to the
radio for today program about Liz Truss
I was actually reflecting with a couple
of journalists earlier I I've known Liz
truss for many years and I can't think
of another time where she's changed her
mind on anything right anything at all
I just wonder whether you wanted to take
that comment back given that I mean my
my immediate checklist would include
brexit the royal family a her political
party she was liberal Democrat and now a
45p tax rate would you would you take
back this idea that she's never changed
her mind yeah you're right you're right
yeah so you're right
no no you're right Peters I was a bit
Lucy with my words I mean actually she
changed her mind on brexit afterwards
she didn't switch from leave to remain
during the campaign and I'll forgive her
for what she said as a teenager when she
was a republican on a particular policy
decision though what I was trying to get
across to Nick Robinson on The Today
program this morning is when she digs in
her heels they usually stay dug in I
guess over five years or 20 years you
might change your mind on a particular
policy position but I've never seen her
change her mind in 20 minutes which is
what seems to have happened over this uh
45p tax rate really quite extraordinary
I've got a lot of sympathy with Liz
truss's views I think you said just
before the ad break the appears that I
have full confidence in her I see the
world much the same way that she does I
think tax is way too high government
spending needs to come over under
control and regulation is too tight in
Britain in that broad Vision this trust
and I would agree but if you want to
move the country in that way you've got
to execute it that's not the job for an
economics think tank we just produce
ideas we're not politicians it's the
jobs are the politicians to execute it
and I find some of the decisions they've
made really quite extraordinary
not the top rate of income tax look it's
gratifying to see you chucking your
great friend under the bus I wasn't
expecting that but let me just ask you
this given that the varying big number
of policy initiatives that were
announced in this mini budget which of
them do you personally disagree with
then would you have lifted the cap on
Bank
let me finish would you have lifted the
cap on Banker bonuses uh would you
reduce it yes you would would you have
reduced the tax from 45 to 40 yes okay
would you have put a windfall tax on
energy companies
no right so basically you you agree with
every single thing I'm happy with it
right so you agree with everyone I've
spent 150 .
we're talking about each other which we
criticize let me just let me just finish
my question so it would seem to me that
you are entirely in agreement with the
very many budget which you've just spent
the last two minutes attacking for the
execution how would you have executed
the same thing
but the I would have preferred if it was
a choice and often these things are
choices peers as you know probably sort
of focused on vat rather than income tax
I don't mind income tax been cut I think
all taxes are probably too high the bit
of a mini budget which we came straight
out of the chats uh traps criticizing
the outset was the 150 billion pound
energy deal you've got to have a package
to support poorer households to make
sure they can get through the winter but
this is absolutely extraordinarily
overblown deal and we criticized it at
the time ahead of the mini budget you
don't need to subsidize people heating
their indoor swimming pools absolutely
ludicrous you need to direct help or
poorer households they've decided to go
supernova on it 150 billion pounds I
mean the two billion pounds on the 45p
rate is almost not over here nor there I
think they might have to revisit that
now make sure that's targeted spend less
but director of the poorer household all
right so I like the general direction
the thinking of the Liz truss regime but
just because I like the direction the
car's going in doesn't mean I approve of
them when they smashed the car well I
couldn't agree more
um not a speculation about who funds
your organization can you give me the
top three
funders
I'm not sure I even know them off the
top of my head we've got to break down
peers on our website we offended by
people who support free markets we don't
Dockside owners we don't list their
names and dresses in the public domain
uh if you want free market ideas to be
spread please do send us a check you can
go to ia.org dot UK there's a donate
page if you doubt that we would use any
pound of your money to do anything other
than to promote free market ideas
without fear or favor try this send us a
check to try and get us to say something
that isn't free market and your check
will be returned okay would you send any
checks to support quasi-quartings
futurist Chancellor or should somebody
who's executed a plan so
catastrophically badly be invited to
leave his office
well hang on if you want to support an
individual politician don't send any
money near me that's up to political
positions
made an embarrassing political U-turn
I mean that's a political
I think probably not it's an extremely
embarrassing U-turn they they sort of
looked like they were willing to die on
this political Hill over a two billion
pound tax cut actually a rounding error
in the overall fiscal plan this is what
they've tried to do is to stem the
bleeding on this they thought they were
probably going to lose anyway so try and
get it over with here's the problem
though right the next time that
quasi-quarting stands up and says
something will it be you turned on if
Michael Govan Branch hats complain about
it so even if you stem this particular
issue what are we supposed to think in
the future when they're supposed to
bring boys
I agree with you so why shouldn't she
just fire him put him out of his misery
because we're not going to trust him
again I'm not
appears I'm not a politician I run an
economics think tank we try to get
people to think so you literally just
given me an exceptionally particularly
possible if you've just given me an
exceptionally articulate explanation for
why you shouldn't be in the job why why
shouldn't he be fired because if he
isn't fired then as long as long as he's
there with no credibility this trust is
going to be highly damaged
well you say no credibility peers this
is a political question or one for the
money markets clearly the Prime Minister
and the chancellor need to regain their
credibility pretty fast on a range of
flanks I would suggest within their own
political party certainly amongst the
public I think you just highlighted
another disastrous opinion Poll for the
conservative party yeah and also on the
markets they lost credibility badly in
all those three spaces yeah uh they're
going to try they've tried to stem the
bleeding by killing this one I think
they've got to regain credibility both
the problem is
and that means yeah it's like giving
your car though isn't it to someone you
know has just driven the previous cast
right over the cliff it's like why would
you do that anyway Martin wood thank you
for joining me I appreciate it well a
prang a prang maybe not necessarily okay
full Cliff onto the rocks with a dollar
provocation thank you I think it's a
major prang thank you for joining me I
appreciate it uh John what do you make
of that because it seems to me that he
was sort of his same I agree with
everything that was in the middle budget
I don't like the way they sold it I mean
do those two things are they consistent
not calling at a mini budget sorry
massive budget there was a budget
gigantic budget the biggest issue with
what we said there is you've got this
this statement that this was in in
search of growth right it's a progress
policy but the the evidence for the the
for the budget was delivered for the
policies that were delivered producing
growth is is very very minimal it's I'm
not look I'm not saying just you know to
make sure I don't set an off here I'm
not saying that I'm getting taxes more
fun simply will not produce growth but
over Decades of research from dozens of
countries there's very little evidence
that it moves the needle either way but
what it does do is it it distributes
income from the poor to the rich or at
least it keeps it in the pockets of the
Rich and that when it comes to whether
we're calling this communication and
miscommunication it's just obviously
toxic so you're essentially shuffling
things around on the board not
necessarily going to produce any growth
is costing the government is requiring
more more borrowing and is making the
rich rich quite interesting Emily I
thought that he you know he was on the
radio only a few hours ago saying I've
known list trust a long time she's never
done a U-turn and now he's immediately
Backtrack on that tonight isn't he and
distances himself from that comment
because he knows it's ridiculous a lot
of the way she's I think he is right
they do agree on her plan the sort of
central planks of her plan but what
everyone is saying is the execution of
it was so awful and if you go back to
say the Cameron and Osborne government
they did cut tax they did put austerity
through but they did they prepared the
ground for a very very long time they
went they also had a mandate so things
like suddenly we're hearing she's going
to have to put tax cuts in to pay for
This Disaster well we didn't hear that
in the summer we didn't hear over the
summer that this was what her mini
budget was going to look like silly
things like not get well not silly like
catastrophic that she didn't want the
obr in it just both of them just like
they've made
and you're winning
torment of hearing the truth no it said
I was just wondering when I might
actually get a chance to say now's your
chance thank you very much because
considering it's won against three I
thought it might be quite nice if I got
a chance to say what I think which is
this I agree with him and with Liz truss
that tax cutting does actually promote
growth and when you look at what
Thatcher did that is what happened and I
do very strongly believe that if we're
to take any advantage of brexit at all
then it made sense to seek a competitive
advantage against the EU which was the
point of the bankers bonuses but
um the execution of it what I think went
wrong was very straightforwardly as I've
tried to say several times it wasn't
properly explained right and the view
out there is exactly you've had a lot I
know but you you're agreeing we're both
agreeing with each other the executed
simply think we all disagree with you we
all agree with you well I've just said
exactly the same thing let me finish the
sentence Madam and I don't remember
stopping you finishing your sentences
let's move on to uh I don't get to
finish the sentence okay thank you
finish your sentences
are ridiculous no I'm not being
ridiculous I'm just trying to say that
it was not you weren't talking about
explanation out there people think this
was just about benefiting the rich right
they didn't hear the rationale behind it
right and what we should have had uh was
a lot of that preparation but she didn't
have the time if this was the first one
if this was the first week and if you
have this was the first week of an
entire parliamentary run of four or five
years she would have had the time she
didn't have it if you haven't had the
time to do the groundwork don't do a
mini budget well don't do a year round
don't do a U-turn if you believe that
what you are doing never mind the U-turn
mind the Utah
no you don't you like me no I mind it
because the original policy on which it
was based was completely flawed well
therefore you like the Utah huh
therefore you like the YouTube I like it
oh you do yeah
I think it should have happened but it
should have happened with more
explanation I want to turn to Ukraine
Elon Musk the richest man in the world
for some bizarre reasons decided to go
on Twitter today and he said Ukraine
Russia peace redo elections of annex
regions under U.N supervision Russia
leaves if that's one of the people
Crimea formerly part of Russia as it has
been since 1783 until Chris Johnson
State water supply to Crimea assured
Ukraine remains neutral
he then says this is highly likely to be
the outcome in the end that's the
question of how many died before them
also worth noting he says that a
possible albeit unlikely outcome from
his conflict is nuclear war the
Ukrainian ambassadors in Germany
responded by saying F off is my very
diplomatic reply to you Elon Musk Gary
Kasparov the chess champion of course
Russian this is moral idiocy repetition
of Kremlin propaganda a betrayal of
Ukrainian courage and sacrifice and puts
a few minutes browsing Crimea on
Wikipedia over the current horrific
reality of Putin's bloody war John I
mean bizarre thing for Elon Musk to get
involved with is now doing other polls
meantime president zielinski has just
tweeted his own poll in which he says
which Elon must you prefer the one that
supported Ukraine or the one who
supports Russia what do you make of this
look I think Elon Musk spent a lot of
time on Twitter doesn't he he seems to
generate a lot of heat not not a huge
amount of light and I think saying
something like let's just have
Democratic elections in those regions
isn't bit like saying let's just have
proper Democratic elections in Russia I
think right it's it's it's fanciful in
the current situation it's certainly not
anything Putin would allow so I you know
I'd treat this the same way as I treat
everything Elon tweets and kind of
ignore it I mean the I've got to say the
rather Lively Ukrainian ambassador to
Germany the only outcome from this is
now no Ukrainian will ever buy your
effing Tesla crap so good luck to Elon
Musk seems like open wall now from uh
the ukrainians towards Elon Musk but
what are you making is a strange thing
for him to get weighed into but I think
Kasparov summed up everything that I
would say it does look like he literally
went on Wikipedia tried to sort of up
himself on History
um tweeted something actually in the
middle of a war when you if you if you
actually if you'd even read or bothered
to look at what's happening and the
death and the devastation and the
torture and the rape you just wouldn't
it just looks so blase and then putting
a poll at the end I know some people
like discuss it but actually other
people really will just think it's
absolutely disgusting horrifying
somebody could explain to me in words of
one syllable why we are even concerned
about what Elon Musk thinks why should I
worry about what Elon Musk thinks well I
think on this issue a good point because
it's still certainly clearly not his
error of expertise but he is the richest
man in the world he's highly influential
with a lot of young people but we have
to listen to what he says no but you
can't ignore him can he I can you can do
and do
you think we should just ignore what he
said I can ignore it completely it is
the most abysmal rubbish and why anybody
would want to waste time on your Serious
Program discussing such rot I don't know
well thank you we're talking of serious
issues on this program McDonald's has
decided to introduce happy meals for
adults
and my question for all three of you
before we let you go uh well one of you
anyway is what would your Happy Meal be
to make you happy as an adult you know
that is a very question I think fish
fingers just bring back you know happy
challenges memories to me you know just
a nice plate of beige Foods yes maybe
some some crispy smiley faces fingers
great cool Emily I was going to say
roast chicken but actually when I was 13
I ate 13 fish fingers in one sitting so
I might have to agree with you bird's
eye fish beans two fish fingers wow okay
roast lamb with mint sauce and red
currant jelly lots of spuds
[Laughter]
would have yeah mine would be a nice
little steak here it is
so oh I don't know there we go nice
little fillet steak I think with some
fries you tuck in pears we'll just there
we go and a nice little bottle though
what's a little Argentinian malbait to
wash it all down with and there's of
course the obligatory cigar
this will be my Happy Meal instead of my
Troy there we go
Happy Days
they are McDonald's that's all you gotta
do cheers everyone we'll see you after
the break
thanks John cool cheers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back captains Tom Moore the hero
of the pandemic who raised nearly 33
million pounds for the NHS has had a
memorial to him targeted by climate
activists in a video widely condemned
online protests to wearing a t-shirt
really ends private jets it seemed
pouring human feces and urine Over The
World War II Veterans Memorial joining
me now is Kai Bartlett is from the
campaign group and UK private jets and
Emily's still here Kai thank you for
coming in did you support this action
foreign
yeah you do you think that it's right
and proper for someone to go to the
memorial to this great man who served
his country in World War II who then at
the age of 99
raised tens of millions of pounds for
NHS workers in the pandemic by walking
through extreme discomfort up and down
his garden and a memorial has made him
after he dies
and you think it's okay to go and
throw urine and feces all over it
well I mean we say that we care for what
Captain Tom stood for you know what you
know everything you just described you
don't really do everything you just
describe is like Really Brave and
inspiring and everything but as far as
you know the Public's concerned you know
we're we're acting like what he stands
for is just you know meaningless
what he stands for his meaning is which
which part serving his country in World
War II to fight for our freedom and
democracy or raising tens of millions of
pounds for NHS workers and a pandemic
which part of that did you find so
meaningless I'm saying um the UK public
is acting like
um it's all meaningless because
um basically you know we're in a
situation where our you know everyone
sort of knows you know I've talked to
quite a lot of the public and everyone
sort of knows that we're ruining our
kids future and everyone's a sort of
fine with that and it's just like this
how does attacking Tom Moore a statue
how does that assist the children's
future how does it
because you know it it's just a little
it's a little glimmer of the truth
you've thrown an excrement over a statue
of somebody who was totally selfless in
his life what is this glimmer of truth
that comes from this
that maybe things aren't actually okay
yeah you know what it made me do though
like so many of these protests this is a
particularly disgusting example of it
you make me want to do the complete
opposite you make me want to go and
literally get on a private plane tonight
literally want me to do the opposite so
any attempt by you to try and influence
public thinking
or get support for your cause
you're living for the birds I mean this
is one of the most disgusting things I
think I've ever had to see that this
great man who I had a lot of time for
and with interviewed him at length for
my life story show and what a life story
he had that this great man should be so
disgustingly abused in his death
by your organization
is repellent do you understand that
public opinion won't be supporting you
there'll be people watching this
thinking it's disgusting and that you by
supporting it are disgusting
like is people sort of say you know like
you're not going to get the public on
side with this sort of thing you know
that's what what people tend to say and
if you think about what that actually
means it's we're not going to get the
public on side to care about their own
children that's what why should we care
about anything to do with you when
you've shown so lack of care for the
family of Captain to Tom one of whom has
already contacted me one of his
daughters absolutely horrified by what
you've done to her father's Memorial
we're sort of in an epidemic of
pretending and saying that we care but
not acting like it I'm asking you where
your care is for the family of captains
to Tom where your care is for his legacy
and memory where is your care for them
why should anyone care about what you
care about if you show such a disgusting
and repulsive lack of care for someone
like Captain sir Tom
I mean you can you can say all these
things about me and things okay
it doesn't change the fact that the UK
people don't care about their own
children right so you've got no regrets
about this your organization doing this
the situation is is that
um
we're going to continue doing this sort
of thing we're going to keep throwing
feces nearing over very very popular
public figure memorials and statues
we're going to go next Churchill Mandela
where were you where will you stop with
this
situation is is that the government's
you know murdering our children's future
and people aren't standing up to it and
they're also not standing up to this all
right take a short break come back with
more on this and Emily your reaction
after the break
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
well welcome welcome back still with
protester Kai Bartlett from end UK
private jets who supports the pouring of
human feces in urine over the memorial
to Captain to Tom also here with Ann and
Emily Emily what do you make of this
I think I'd just like to try and get to
the bottom of what the Met what the
message you were trying to get across
was so as I read it Kai is that you saw
this as a man so this is not you
insulting the man although it I it's
it's looking like that you saw this man
had given his life nearly died giving
his life for his country had done
amazing things and is like a sort of
wonderful
um uh stand up uh person in society it
also fought for us in the war
and I don't think and tell me if I'm
wrong the excrement was to show that as
a country because we're not taking the
future of our country seriously we are I
don't know whether I can use this word I
won't use the word pooing on his I don't
want to say the more partially you are
pooing on his
um
memory I suppose so it's not that you're
doing the throwing of the excrement is
that you're trying to say that Society
is Wrecking what he stood for
him it's a very generous interpretation
of what they actually did this
organization literally human extras
I'm trying to interpret what they tried
I think together I don't think they need
to either interpret it understand it or
excuse it yes but I think we should try
and understand you know I do condemn it
because I think it's totally the wrong
way to go around getting people to stop
flying jets I think it's going to get
people to know your message and focus on
that are your family support I mean we
know that the family of the person that
did it has come out and been critical
are your family supportive of you
supporting this
um just wanted to say you've got it
exactly right the the and you know what
the intention yeah but I don't think the
intentions I understand that a lot of
young people feel very angry about
what's happening we've got a government
that's doing green levees but I do think
very strongly that actions like this are
quite hard to interpret and you you have
taken something that was
um
meant to pay you know pay our respects
to this man and I don't think he would
have thought that was the best way to go
about this this was a man who walked how
many miles I'm sorry look Emily I
appreciate your effort to try and get
inside the um
we should at least try and understand
actually I'm not sure we do actually
because I think if you're going to show
such woeful disrespect for someone like
Captain to Tom I don't know why we
should respect you or anything that
you're causing I believe let me ask let
me ask let me ask you guys because I
think does your family support you
supporting what happened to this
Memorial
um some people do and some people really
don't right
and the ones who don't what do they say
to you is your own family members
um you know they say it's hugely
disrespectful and you know of course it
is and you know the way that the UK way
of life you know is you know spitting on
his grave really let's be honest with
ourselves let's not lie to ourselves you
know we all sort of know that we're
destroying our generation my
generation's future and everyone's just
sort of like thinking that it's fine
right actually it's not spitting on his
grave it is urinating and defecating on
his statue which is there as a memorial
to him and it's disgusting and I say to
you again if you've got a proper cause
that you want to fight and you want to
get public support this is the complete
opposite way to go about it I can tell
you already my phone is blowing up
people's going this is disgusting these
people are disgusting none of them
saying God you know what this really
makes me want to stop using a private
plane ever again nobody is saying that
you have any opposite effect to what you
think
just making people hate you why would
you want that
I think some people are going to realize
that we're all sort of living in an
illusion that we're you know all the
sort of living a life everything's fine
it's not we sort of complain on Twitter
that you know about things but we don't
step into the real world and actually
sort it out that's the use lots of
people are trying to sort out the issue
of climate change lots of people world
leaders are all meeting regularly now to
try and sort this out they fly using
private debts to those meetings how else
are they supposed to get there there's
lots of other ways do you ever use
planes
uh no when did you last fly
um when I was like like sex like
everyone should stop Flying I'm talking
about private jets but usually everyone
should stop Flying
um well yeah there are there are use
cases you know there are some islands
that you can't access without using a
plane yes okay think about it all right
there are better ways to make your case
this was disgusting but thank you for
coming in and thank you for coming in
appreciate it uh that's it for me
whatever you're up to Keep It Uncensored
good night
[Music]
so I think my sister is my her husband's
property yes
[Music]
I have a hundred business tips I'm going
to teach you
[Music]
this is talk TV news
good evening I'm Emily Rose Adams the
Chancellor's admitted his economic plans
have caused a little turbulence and is
set to bring forward his next financial
statement from the 23rd of November to
this month it comes after quasiqua
saying you turned on plans to scrap the
top rate of income tax for the highest
earners following a huge backlash
meanwhile labor has seen more huge poll
leads over the Tories this time of 25
and 28 points the parties accused the
chancellor of laughing at the financial
chaos caused by his mini budget and the
man accused of murdering nine-year-old
Olivia Pratt Corbell in Liverpool will
remain in custody until he faces trial
in March 34 year old Thomas cashman's
also been charged with the attempted
murder of Olivia's mum Cheryl and the
man he chased into their house
that's all for now we'll have more after
the talk
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you